hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the video grand prix 2022 it's a
daniel dubo versus vincent kamer this is
the return match if you remember in
round one it was a really crazy game
vincent had a better position than
double equalized and then uh anything
could have happened but in the end the
game ended in a draw uh but now we have
a clash in round four so let's check it
out there is quite a lot to enjoy uh
duba with the white pieces opens with e4
and vincent goes for the karo khan
defense he plays c6 with d4 d5 and now
e5 do with not interested in trading
pawns he goes for the advanced variation
of the car khan
bishop to f5 knight to f3 and now that
the bishop has been nicely developed we
close our setup with e6 uh we have
bishop to e2 and now black will waste
one more tempo at the attack white's
center so c5
we have bishop to e3 defending the pawn
and now queen to b6 putting pressure on
that b2 pawn and if you don't know what
you're doing this could be a little bit
scary as there is a lot of pressure on
that center knight is coming to c6 your
b2 point is hanging but if you know what
you're doing you can just play knights
to c3 and offer that b2 pawn now there's
no
way to actually trap a black's queen but
that's not what white's trying to do the
idea is if you capture here we're going
to play queen b1 and now after we trade
let's say captures captures the b7 pawn
is hanging and after b6 uh b7 b6 we're
going to play d captures on c5 after b
captures there's knight b5 uh
threatening knight to c7 check to win
the rook so king d8 and now knight to d6
uh an excellent square for tonight also
we're blocking the bishop defending the
c5 pawn so we're ready to capture this
and black will just have to keep give up
the knight for the bishop here captures
captures and now let's say knight to d7
we are defending the pawn now rook b7
and uh white will always have this um a
little extra time to keep on pushing for
for the sacrifice the pawn so not really
something you want to do with black so
instead we have knight to c6 the camera
just continues developing and not do
both castles but now uh it's perfectly
fine to capture the b2 pawn so queen
captures on b2 now queen b1 we simply
trade in castle queenside there's no
worry about the b7 pawn hanging and the
queen will king will be very safe so
queen to e1 uh defending the knight
because that also was hanging c captures
on d4 and now not knight captures on d4
because then bishop to b4 could be
annoying uh first bishop captures on d4
now the knight is defended twice so
no point in going bishop to b4 right
away first we capture knight captures
and now bishop to b4 we are threatening
the uh to pick up the knight here so do
both goes knight d to b5 threatening
knight to c7 check but also just
defending the c390 that's very important
uh bishop to a5 guarding the c7 square
and now rook to b1 so giving up the c2
pawn as well
queen captures on c2 and now rook to c1
attacking the queen queen has to move
and now we play knight to a4 you could
also throw in a nice knight to d6 check
but first knight to a4 attacking the
queen uh we have bishop capture sunny
one this is a queen trade also uh knight
captures on b2 and now as the bishop is
hanging bishop to a5 and now duboff
takes this opportunity to play knight to
d6 with check
we have king to e7 and now knight
captures and b7 so he grabs the b7 pawn
but he's still uh down down upon and the
bishop on a5 is hanging so here we have
bishop back to d8 and now knight
captures on the e8 we have king captures
on the 8th and rook after d1 so kymer is
up upon but he's very much behind in
development he still has to develop the
rook the knight and this rook here so he
starts with rook to b8 makes sense it's
an open file you develop it with tempo
the knight is hanging but now knight to
c4 as the the d5 pawn is pinned so you
are bringing the knight to the d6 and
the black is helpless uh
in preventing this as he has a light
square bishop and the knight has quite a
few a few jumps before reaching the d6
square and if you try something like
let's say 97 we're gonna play knight e6
bishop to g6 it's a it's a fine position
but maybe you're gonna have a hard time
bringing this rook into the game so
vincent wants to
play something different he plays g5
first as he knows knight is coming here
so he wants to play bishop to g6 but at
least he will already have played g5 and
then maybe you can start pushing so here
knight d6 attacking the bishop bishop to
g6 and now rook to d4 uh grabbing
control of the fort rank also uh rook to
a4 going after the a7 pawn will be a key
move in many of the lines so here we
have knight to e7 uh vincent continues
development now even knight to f5 can be
played attacking the the rook and the
knight so maybe you can force a trade
there
and now simply g4 taking away the f5
square from the black knight and now
comes rook to b6 um
the idea is uh
well black is actually okay in this
position but you have to find king to d7
and it's hard to understand king to d7
it's not like you can bring the rook
into the game i mean you can play rook
to d8 but then your king is just stuck
on d7
the idea is that after something like
bishop to b5 check you just capture the
bishop and after knight captures you you
now play knight to c6 and you continue
playing this you are up upon
and your position is is perfectly fine
but uh
of course it's not easy to find if you
play rook to a4 yes we're putting
pressure on this pawn here and now we
can play rook to b8 and now of course if
you capture on a7 now you are attacking
the knight twice we're gonna capture an
e5 knight captures on e5 and you can see
that the black spawn structure is really
really solid and the black will have all
the need to counter plate the
counterweights um
outside past pawn and also just being
down the exchange so this is the way to
go however vincent played rook to b6 and
it's not that it's a bad move it's a bad
move if daniel has a winning move here
and there is one winning move here it's
the only winning move in the position
it's the one vincent missed uh
as he played this so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the move
vincent missed while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being a truly a
true rulopasian and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course bishop to b5 this is the move
that wins and now when you see it of
course you also believe it uh so what
can what can black do here and what is
white even doing uh well to give you a
quick uh
quick tour let's say we attacked the
bishop with with a6 we're just going to
play rook to a4 and now there's really
not all that much you can do you're
going to lose this pawn and of course if
you capture the bishop then rook a8
check king d7 rook the a7 check king to
d8 and now rook c to c7 and that's it
there's really not all that much to try
here uh you can move the knight rook to
d7 checkmate or or something in in those
lines so instead after bishop to b5 uh
vincent just brings the rook back we
have rook back to b8 and now we have
rook to a4 so again the rook is coming
to the seventh rank so knight to c8
defending this spawn uh hoping to
prevent this somehow but again uh it's
completely winning for white there are
there are a couple of ways you can win
this uh you could just play a passive
rook to c5 but that's not fun daniel
goes for the uh quickest way to win and
that is rook captures on c8 so a
temporary uh
exchange sacrifice but it doesn't matter
rook captures on c8 now comes rook
captures on a7 and how do you play here
rook to d7 is already the threat of
checkmate you have to move the rook so
rook to c7 but now the other rook is
falling so rook to a8 to check king to
e7 now rook captures an h8 and now a
white is just up a full piece plus he
has the outside past a pawn so f6 was
played trying to maybe uh
overwork the knight here or rather
overwork the pawn uh but just rook to c8
now there's nothing for vincent to do
here rook to a7 was played and now rook
to c6 and he was in this position on
move 32 that vincent resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh once you move the something
what do you even play let's say rook
captures on a2 we can play rook c7
checking f80 captures on f6 and you are
getting checkmated very quickly here all
of the squares are covered you you have
to go back with the rook and then you're
just out of moves
so
really really a fine game uh vincent uh
i did not make any any big mistake other
than that rook to b6 move but like i
said a king to d7 in this position and
he can play but it's a move that
why would anyone play this it looks uh
so so unnatural uh and
if you if you believe that you can maybe
bring the rook into the game then okay
but this way
an impossible move to find it would seem
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to i wish a
very happy birthday to elena carlsolari
and i would like to thank meadow for
breaking into the room at the precise
right moment daniel silverberg john
black and patrick mulcair for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event
until it ends thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent start of
your week